bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
émission minute forme je suis Nicolas
votre coach aujourd'hui nous allons voir
le mouvement du box jump nous sommes
avec Anaïs aujourd'hui bonjour Anaïs
comment vas-tu très très bien je te
remercie tu es prêt pour le prochain
mouvement je vous expliquais ce
mouvement de box jump vous avez à
l'occurrence aujourd'hui un rocher nous
pouvons utiliser un banc ou un petit
muret si vous êtes chez vous allez
démarrer légèrement fléchi sur vos
jambes pour effectuer un quart de squat
vous allez pousser sur vos jambes en
utilisant les bras et atterrir en quart
de squat également vous allez tendre les
jambes suffisamment contractant
légèrement les cuisses deux possibilités
descendre un pas après l'autre si vous
débutez si vous êtes à l'aise
vous tendez et vous sautez hop d'accord
tu démarrer sur la première en marchant
et après si tu es à l'aise tu accélères
un petit peu de cette manière je t'en
prie à toi
et ça a été capté un tout petit peu tes
pieds au départ pensez avoir une bonne
ancrage dans le sol vas-y c'est parti ça
et arrivé en haut tu tends les jambes et
tu redescends excellent elle va essayer
d'accélérer le mouvement ça va faire
monter le rythme cardiaque
tant bien les jambes arriver en haut et
tu descends ce temps voilà la même chose
tu peux utiliser tes bras n'hésitez pas
à utiliser vos bras pour monter
davantage encore une
très bien tu t'arrêtes comment tu te
sens Anaïs où est-ce que tu as son
travail
le cardio est-ce que tu as senti des
muscles travaillent également dis-moi
lesquelles
derrière la jambe très bien nous allons
étirer après cet exercice le muscle
fessier je vous conseille d'avoir une
jambe fléchie légèrement vous allez
placer la jambe opposée au dessus du
genou et vous allez grouper le tout pour
sentir vraiment au niveau des fessiers
vous tirez
cet exercice des deux côtés bien entendu
prenez le temps de relâcher doucement
entre chaque répétition tu t'installes
je te redresse tu places ton pied sur le
genou posé et tu ramènes le tout vers
toi attraper avec les deux mains
tu essayes de tirer vers toi
pour sortir au niveau des fessiers ça va
tu maintiens une vingtaine de secondes
tu relâches tout doucement et tu passes
sur l'autre côté
très bien
pensez à vous installer progressivement
et à relâcher progressivement pour
chacun de vos étirements
Anaïs merci beaucoup à très bientôt
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
rendez-vous dans un prochain épisode de
minutes forme box jump faites 10 à 50
répétitions 2 à 4 séries une à deux fois
par semaine pour éviter une mauvaise
réception toujours effectuer une flexion
de jambes au départ et à la réception